♪
>> Tucker: IN THE PAST TWO
YEARS THE MEDIA HAVE ADOPTED
NEW PRINCIPLE IF SOMEONE IS
CONNECTED TO THE CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION, THAT PERSON
CAN BE TARGETED FOR
DESTRUCTION FOR ANY REASON
OR NO REASON AT ALL.
AND IT'S ALL VIRTUOUS
BECAUSE THE PRESIDENT IS
EVIL.
WELL, UNTIL LAST MONTH,
DAVID SORENSEN WAS A SPEECH
WRITER IN THE WHITE HOUSE
AND "THE WASHINGTON POST"
ACCUSED HIM OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
WHY DID THEY DO THIS?
BECAUSE OF THE WORD OF HIS
EX-WIFE.
SORENSON LOST HIS JOB.
HE SAID THE POST HAD NO
EVIDENCE THAT HE EVER DID
ANYTHING WRONG.
THE POST HAD NO COURT
RECORDS, NO POLICE REPORT.
NO EVIDENCE, NO PICTURES,
NOTHING.
AND NOW HIS LIFE HAS BEEN
DESTROYED.
DAVID SORENSON JOINS US
TONIGHT WITH HIS STORY.
DAVID, I WANT TO SAY AT THE
OUTSET THAT WE HAVE NEVER
MET.
I HAVE NEVER SPOKEN TO YOU
IN MY LIFE BEFORE.
THIS I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT YOUR MARRIAGE AND I
DON'T EVEN KNOW YOUR
EX-WIFE'S NAME.
WHAT STRUCK ME ABOUT THIS
STORY, NORMALLY I WOULD
NEVER GET INVOLVED IN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS BECAUSE I
KNOW THESE THINGS TEND TO BE
REALLY COMPLICATED.
WHAT STRUCK ME ABOUT THIS
STORY WAS YOU SAID THE POST
HAD LITERALLY NO EVIDENCE,
NO ACTUAL EVIDENCE YOU HAD
DONE ANYTHING WRONG?
>> THAT'S RIGHT, TUCKER.
FIRST OF ALL THESE
ACCUSATIONS ARE COMPLETELY
FALSE AND FAB BRIE
INDICATED.
I HAVE NEVER BEEN VIOLENT
WITH ANY WOMAN IN MY ENTIRE
LIFE.
NOT THE WAY I WAS RAISED.
THE POST NONETHELESS ON
THEIR ONGOING WAR AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP DECIDED TO
PUBLISH A STORY BASED ON MY
EX-WIFE'S WORD ALONE THAT I
WAS PHYSICALLY VIOLENT
DURING OUR MARRIAGE.
AND THEY HAD NO EVIDENCE.
I HAVE NEVER HAD A POLICE
REPORT AGAINST ME FOR
VIOLENCE.
I HAVE NEVER HAD A
RESTRAINING ORDER AGAINST ME
AND THREE OF HER FRIENDS
EVEN CAME OUT.
PEOPLE I HAVEN'T SPOKEN WITH
IN YEARS AND SAID THAT SHE
WAS -- HAD A HISTORY OF
INSTABILITY AND DISHUN
NECESSARY CITY AND THEY
WITNESSED HER BEING VIOLENT
AGAINST ME.
IT'S JUST UNBELIEVABLE.
>> Tucker: WAS SHE VIOLENT
AGAINST YOU.
>> SHE WAS, ACTUALLY.
I SENT THE POST AND EVERY
OTHER MEDIA OUTLET THAT
ASKED A 13-PAGE DOCUMENT AS
SOON AS I WAS ACCUSED FULL
OF ITEM
OF TTEM
OF TEXM
OF TEXT MESSAGE AND PHOTO
VIOLENT AGAINST KNEE.
NEVER BROUGHT THIS UP IN THE
DIVORCE WHICH I INITIATED BY
THE WAY.
SIMPLY NOTHING BUT HER WORD
TO GO ON.
IT'S SHAMEFUL ON THE POST'S
PART.
>> Tucker: YOU SAY YOU HAD
DOCUMENTARY EVIDENCE THAT
SHE WAS THE PERPETRATOR OF
VIOLENCE.
DID THE POST RUN THAT
EVIDENCE?
>> NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF, NO
NOT THAT I RECALL.
SHE ACTUALLY ADMITTED TO IT
IN TEXT MESSAGES AND
ADMITTED TO IT IN SUBSEQUENT
INTERVIEWS WITH THE MEDIA.
I ACTUALLY HAD A REPORTER
ONE TIME DURING ALL OF THIS
AND BY THE WAY I SPOKE TO
EVERY REPORTER I COULD.
I WAS VERY TRANSPARENT AND
HAD A REPORTER SAY TO ME
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT SHE WAS
VIOLENT TOWARD ME AND
ESTABLISHED FACT SAY WELL,
YOU KNOW.
WE HEARD THAT HE SAID SOME
PRETTY NASTY THINGS DURING
YOUR MARITAL FIGHTS.
AND I COULDN'T IMAGINE A
REPORTER SAYING THE SAME
THING TO A WOMAN WHOSE
HUSBAND HAD BEEN ADMIT LID
VIOLENT TOWARD HER.
DOUBLE STANDARD.
>> Tucker: WHICH REPORTER
WAS THAT THAT SAID THAT.
>> THIS WAS FROM A LOCAL TV
STATION UP IN MAINE WHERE I
WAS WORKING BEFORE MY JOB AT
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Tucker: THAT'S PRETTY
SHOCKING.
OBVIOUS QUESTION IS IF YOUR
WIFE, EX-WIFE ADMITTED USING USE
VIOLENCE AGAINST YOU AND
EVIDENCE THERE IS.
YOU DENIED USED VIOLENCE
AGAINST HER.
NO EVIDENCE THAT YOU DID.
WHY DID YOU LOSE YOUR JOB?
>> WELL, BECAUSE I WORKED
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THAT'S ALL THERE IS TOO IT.
NOT EVEN A QUESTION IF THAT
STORY WOULD HAVE RUN IF I
DIDN'T WORK THERE.
AND PRESIDENT TRUMP, THANK
GOD FOR HIM, AT LEAST, IS
THEIR ONGOING BIAS LIKE FEW
PEOPLE ARE.
ON TOP OF ALL OF THAT,
TUCKER, FOR MY PART, I
PASSED A POLYGRAPH EXAM
PROVING MY INNOCENCE.
THE SITTING GOVERNMENT OF GOVERO
THE SITTING GOVERNMENT OF GOVERR
THE SITTING GOVERNMENT OF GOVERF
THE SITTING GOVERNMENT OF GOVERT
THE SITTING GOVERNMENT OF GOVERE
STATE MY FORMER BOSS OFFERED
MY JOB BACK.
HE HAD THAT MUCH FAITH IN
ME.
PEOPLE WE KNEW CAME OUT
PUBLICLY SAID THEY DIDN'T
BELIEVE HER AND TOTAL FAITH
IN ME.
IT'S ONE SIDED THING.
>> Tucker: IT'S CERTAINLY
ORWELLIAN AND YOU ARE NOT
ALONE IN THIS.
THIS IS THE FIRST TIME WE